[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 le journal nous
sommes le 17 octobre voici les titres
un grand séminaire sur le recrutement
s'est tenue aujourd'hui à trappes le but
créer un véritable plan d'action amples
informations dans l'agglomération nous
étions sur place et puis le 12 octobre
dernier se tenait au centre sportif les
pyramides à port-marly les universités
des mairies 2016 plus de 400 personnes
étaient présentes au rendez vous c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
automobilistes franciliens une nouvelle
taxe pourrait voir le jour ce nouveau
prélèvement dit taxe carburant doit
permettre une hausse de la taxe
intérieure de consommation sur les
produits énergétiques
explications avec nicolas kerry l'oit
avec plus de 5 millions de chômeurs en
france le chômage est l'une des
préoccupations des français l'une des
armes pour lutter contre celui-ci c'est
le recrutement un grand séminaire s'est
tenu aujourd'hui à trappes le but créer
un véritable plan d'action emploi
formation notre journaliste anne laure
l'anguille étaient sur place
une petite centaine de formateurs
recruteurs et entreprises du territoire
sont venus échanger leurs idées ce matin
si les yvelines reste un département
dynamique il n'en demeure pas moins dans
les moyennes nationales avec un taux de
chômage d'environ 10% en cause notamment
la difficulté des entreprises à trouver
des candidats
la plupart des entreprises en tout cas
ce que ce qu'on a constaté aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elles ont des besoins de
recrutement dont d'emploi c'est-à-dire
des besoins réels d'emplois et qu'elle
beaucoup de difficultés pour trouver des
personnes correspondant à ces emplois
c'est surtout dans les métiers innovants
ou émergents que trouver un
collaborateur restent difficiles par le
manque de faudra y est voilà par exemple
ça c'est pas un métier innovant non
c'est un métier qui innerve à nouveau
face à cela l'agglomération de saint
quentin qui organise cette journée se
focalise sur l'orientation aiguiller les
jeunes vers un métier qui leur plaît et
pour lequel existe une demande réelle
des entreprises voilà l'étape
essentielle pour recréer de l'emploi
vous ne pouvez pas imposer à des jeunes
d'un dernier filière générale s'ils
n'ont pas envie ce n'est pas possible
vous ne pouvez pas dire à un jeune il
faut que tu fasses un bac s parce que
c'est bien pour toi ce n'est pas
possible par contre il faut également
que ce jeune n'a soit conscient qu'il ya
des filières techniques cette journée
autour de la formation va permettre deux
actions la création d'un observatoire
des métiers émergents et l'organisation
de rendez vous annuel avec l'ensemble
des centres de formation du territoire
objectif prévoir les défis d'avenir
l'université des mairies des yvelines
s'est tenue le 12 octobre à port marly
les élus des 260 de communes des
yvelines où rencontrer leurs homologues
départementaux et régionaux objectif
échanger partager les moyens de gestion
pour faire face à la situation des
finances publiques locales un reportage
signé nicolas landry sur des images
divines premières
tables rondes ateliers formations sur la
gouvernance des communes voilà le
programme de l'édition 2016 de
l'université des mairies des yvelines
élus communaux départementaux régionaux
et parlementaires se sont retrouvés
mercredi 12 octobre pour échanger
notamment sur la situation budgétaire
des communes yvelinoise très exactement
dans les yvelines le chiffre de des
dotations aux communes étaient en 2014
de 300 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui il est de 205 millions
d'euros les communes et les
intercommunalités où on était j'allais
dire les généreux donateurs un retour à
l'équilibré critiqué ces derniers temps
sur l'augmentation de 66 % de la taxe
foncière le président du département des
yvelines tente de se justifier
tout comme la région concernant les
économies réalisées un département c'est
la filiale je le dis pour ceux qui
travaillent dans l'entreprise policiers
d'être pédagogique c'est la filiale d'un
grand groupe qui s'appelle l'état et
s'était pas fait n'importe quoi est en
faillite et donc transfert dans la
filiale que nous sommes tous ces risques
pour y est c'est pour ça que nous sommes
dans cette situation de grande
difficulté oui on demande à tout le
monde de faire des économies mais cet
argent je le réinvestis et pourquoi je
le réinvestis parce que ce serait un
drame que la france et les communes
notamment ne puisse plus investir parce
qu'on leur coupe les budgets que je suis
à fond sur l'aide aux investissements et
notamment des communes le projet de loi
de finances 2010 est actuellement en
discussion au parlement prévoit une
limitation de la baisse des dotations
aux collectivités locales une mesure
prise suite aux annonces du président
françois hollande en juin dernier
et on continue toujours avec de la
politique et notamment la primaire de la
droite et du centre le 13 octobre
dernier 17 candidats ont passé leur
premier oral lors du premier débat à
l'issue de celui ci alain juppé garde
toujours son avance sur nicolas sarkozy
selon les sondages de son côté le
président du conseil général des
yvelines pierre bédier a donné son avis
sur les candidats au micro de michael et
lui d'euros moi j'ai signé pour un
nicolas sarkozy
je n'ignore rien des défauts de nicolas
sarkozy mais je connais aussi ses
qualités je pense qu'il a une que les
autres n'ont pas c'est qu'il a déjà été
président de la république et que donc
il sera tout de suite opérationnels
alain juppé a exercé des responsabilités
très importante mais n'a jamais été
président et les autres qu'il s'agit de
françois fillon de bruno le maire de
nathalie kosciusko morizet de
jean-françois copé de jean frédéric
poisson je crois que je les ai tous
citer
aucun nom d'exercer ses responsabilités
or il faut savoir deux choses maintenant
c'est un quinquennat donc dans un
quinquennat si vous perdez six mois au
début pour vous habituer
comme on dit en bon français aux
nouveaux jobs voulait rattraper jamais
le week-end dernier dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche des policiers ont été
pris dans un guet-apens subida
d'échauffourées avec une centaine de
jeunes dans le quartier du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie
pour le moment aucune interpellation n'a
été faite mais aucun blessé n'est à
déplorer cet incident intervient une
semaine après la violente attaque au
cocktail molotov qui a blessé quatre
policiers à viry-châtillon dans
l'essonne
dans le reste de l'actualité la ville
d'elancourt vient d'officialiser son
jumelage avec la ville maltaise datar
une délégation s'est d'ailleurs rendue
dans la ville pour une visite de
plusieurs jours un reportage de michael
et demi d'euros et nicolas willot vite
elles sont désormais jumelles unis par
des liens d'amitié attar ville maltaise
de 10000 habitants et long cours ont
signé il ya quelques jours l'acte de
jumelage qui officialisent leur
rapprochement distante de 1800 km les
deux villes vont pouvoir ainsi
multiplier les échanges culturels ou
sportifs les écoliers également devrait
profiter de ces nouveaux liens tissés en
europe malte en plus
s'exprimant en langue anglaise est bien
entendu c'est important aussi pour nos
jeunes
qui s'il ya un système scolaire très
très innovant et bien entendu on a
besoin d'échanger avec la
visioconférence avec tous les nouveaux
moyens scolaire c'est aussi les échanges
scolaires sont très importants dans ce
ce rapprochement bien sûr avec cette
ville de 2002 mme al attar situé en
plein coeur de l'île de malte est devenu
la quatrième ville jumelle d'elancourt
une nouvelle qui ravit le maire de la
commune à malte il ya beaucoup de
mairies qui font des jumelage avec des
villes françaises pour nous c'est notre
première fois
et l'encours est vraiment une belle vie
d' une grande ville plus grande qatar
d'ailleurs
j'espère pouvoir me rendre pour mes
vacances personnelles pour coiffer la
ville d'atar abrite plusieurs sites
historiques et notamment le palais
saint-antoine la résidence officielle du
président de la république maltaise
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
automobilistes franciliens inscrit dans
le projet de loi de finances 2010 est
une hausse de taxe pourrait lui arriver
ce nouveau prélèvement dit taxe
carburant doit permettre une hausse de
la taxe intérieure de consommation sur
les produits énergétiques
l'objectif nicolas en gros ces deux
permettre le financement du passe navigo
unique c'est cela aussi manne pour
justifier cette hausse qui doit encore
être votée avant la fin de l'année la
région présidée par valérie pécresse et
le gouvernement met en avant l'argument
du passe navigo
celui ci est désormais soumis à un tarif
unique 73 euros depuis cet été le tarif
unique lui c'est une mesure qui était
mise en place par l'ancienne majorité
socialiste problème ce tarif unique
entraîne un déficit de 300 millions
d'euros pour le stif le syndicat en
charge des transports en ile de france
et donc pour tenter de combler une
partie de ce déficit haussmann le projet
de loi de finances actuellement discutée
par les parlementaires prévoient une
hausse de la taxe carburant alors
concrètement on va avoir une hausse au
niveau des pompes oui pour les
automobilistes exactement c'est ce que
prévoit le projet de loi une hausse
maximum du litre d'essence de 1 à vagues
le 65 centimes et
1,77 centimes pour le litre de gasoil
soit concrètement et ça semble tout de
même rester raisonnable une hausse
inférieure à 1 euro sur un plein de 50
litres alors à priori elle a l'air
d'être limité mais ça dont je n'ai pas
mal oui effectivement enfin les avis
sont plutôt mitigées du côté des
automobilistes entre ceux qui disent une
nouvelle fois c'est nous qui allons
payer et puis ceux qui comprennent
l'intérêt d'une telle mesure écouter ces
quelques avis sur la question on peut
pas tout avoir gratuit il faut vraiment
donner je suis mentionné des choses sans
ça si tu tombe du ciel j'y crois pas
beaucoup donc du coup c'est un pari un
peu logique et pourquoi pas l'essence
c'est un peu de refuge pour les hommes
politiques pour les diverses
augmentations à tous les niveaux donc
c'est un peu pénalisant et que penser
que l'essence des serait maintenant ça
remonte et tout est bon pour faire payer
plus moi je suis pour améliorer les
transports en commun effectivement le
moyen déterminé du par
effectivement très sympathique pour les
automobilistes ça c'est clair mais d'une
manière générale sur le principe oui
améliorer transports en commun oui la
mesure sera votée par les députés au
plus tard le 23 décembre prochain pour
une mise en place le 1er janvier merci
pour toutes ces précisions nicolas on
passe maintenant au football clap de fin
pour l'équipe de trappes en coupe de
france les journées les joueurs d'armes
nbc se sont inclinés contre les murs ou
au cinquième tour de la compétition lors
d'un match où ils n'ont pas démérité ils
ont perdu 2 1 patrick jacques de dixmude
étaient sur place
un derby vinoy pour ce 5e tour de la
coupe de france ce trappe qui évolue en
ph recevez les bourreaux une équipe de
dh trois divisions dessus des trappistes
le match débute mal pour les saint
quentinois la 19e minute de jeu.les
muriautin marque après un cafouillage un
but qui donne des ailes aux verts la
défense trappistes doit s'employer à
plusieurs reprises pour éviter le but du
break avant la mi temps ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on a à peu près le
même groupe la même défense après
attrape on a toujours eu l'esprit
guerrier donc là ça s'est ressenti
aujourd'hui les autres matches
au retour des vestiaires trappe revient
avec de meilleures intentions et fait
jeu égal avec les bureaux et rouge
exerce un gros pressing et monopolisent
le ballon
on perd 1 0 à la mi temps on a un peu de
mal à rentrer dans le match on a été un
peu secoué à la mi temps on avait dit
qu'on n'avait rien à perdre pas de
pression et on la joue un peu plus
libéré du coup ça s'est ressenti sur la
deuxième mi temps malgré le jeu
développé sur la seconde période les
mureaux marque à la 80e minute sur
corner 2-0 trappe réduit le score dans
les dernières minutes sur penalty par
hamidou sissoko un but anecdotique les
verts l'emportent 2 1 et se qualifie
pour le 6e tour c'est une défaite
logique donc à l'écart de niveau entre
la troupe et achemine d'âge c'est dur
d'avoir un droit dans la maîtrise on a
le sang froid ils ont marqué dans les
moments clés donc après nous on essaie
d'exister mais bon y'a quand même un
écart entre une place en dh on prend le
deuxième but sur un coup de pied arrêté
à dix minutes de la fin ça joue sur des
détails voilà il ya on a vu la
différence de niveau son deuxième but
maintenant c'est à nous de bosser pour
pouvoir le rejoindre un jour tu rappes
va à présent refermer cette parenthèse
coupe de france pour se reconcentrer sur
le championnat
les joueurs d'arnaud mbj son douzième de
ph après trois journées disputées
dimanche si vous étiez à la recherche
d'un vélo pas cher il fallait être à la
deuxième édition de la brocante vos
vélos organisée par le vélo club de
montigny le bretonneux les visiteurs ont
pu découvrir des stands et des
animations toute la journée ecoutez jean
marie bron un des bénévoles tous types
de vélos beaucoup de vélos enfants les
enfants grandissent vite donc ils
peuvent trouver un vélo pas cher ici
mais c'est celui qui n'est plus à la
taille enfin à la taille
il ya des bulles beaucoup de vtt et il y
à des vélos de route aussi la majorité
des vélos que l'on vend on les vend
entre 30 et 80 euros
ça dépend vraiment de l'état du vélo
c'est vrai que l'occasion ça vaut la
peine au vélo des quotas si vite c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de nous
avoir suivis prochaine édition mardi à
18h et en direct bonne soirée
[Musique]